Donald Trump has been tweeting attacks
on protesters from the White House for
days while offering up a suggestion that
the military go in and use more force
against protesters meanwhile Democratic
presidential candidate Joe Biden has
been meeting with protesters he gave a
very good speech yesterday about the
state of the race as well as police
relations in this country and we now
have Democratic senator Elizabeth Warren
joining the protest marches yesterday
marching with her husband and her
absolutely delightful dog a Golden
Retriever named Bailey here is Warren
marching of course with a mask asked by
a protester why is Donald Trump bringing
in the military Warren says because he's
wrong people are protesting peacefully
check it out it is a little bit
difficult to understand all of the audio
because people are wearing masks but I
think you're gonna get the gist of it
[Applause]
[Music]
Elizabeth Warren not being shy about
what is going on she tweeted on Monday
quote the President of the United States
tear-gassed peaceful protesters in order
to clear the way for a useless photo-op
outside the White House just after
vowing to activate the military against
our own people lives and democracy are
in danger I like this you know ok she's
a senator she's not gonna say everything
you or I would necessarily say but she's
being strong and clear here and how
about Bailey the dog at the protest it
really just doesn't get better than a
nice dog joining a movement for sanity
and reason so what's going on with
Warren as VP you all know last week I
interviewed congressman ro Khanna and he
said he believes Warren is the best
choice for VP a Joe Biden is
increasingly getting pressure not to
pick Elizabeth Warren from different
camps okay there are some people who
don't want Warren to be the VP because
they don't like her wealth tax and they
don't want her wealth tax to be made
into the law the reality is that
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax is very
unlikely to be made into the law even if
Elizabeth Warren is vice president
please understand that it's not even
clear Joe Biden supports that there's
another contingent that wants Joe Biden
to choose a black vice-president now
remember Joe Biden already committed to
choosing a female vice president
yesterday on the bonus show we talked
about the call for Joe Biden now to pick
a black female vice president I believe
that the top choices in terms of who's
likely to get it for a black female VP
would be Kamala Harris and maybe Val
Demmings now Kamala Harris is hugely
problematic because of her actions as
California Attorney General given what's
going on right now with the protests it
strikes me as maybe a bad idea to pick
Kamala Harris if in two months the Prout
have died down maybe it's something that
would be less problematic from a PR
perspective although her track record as
California AG is not good
Val Demmings on the other hand would be
an interesting choice
she's a congresswoman from Florida with
a florida or georgia now I believe it's
Florida with a law enforcement
background and I think that that would
be a very interesting pick now there are
people talking about Nina Turner or
Stacey Abrams I know not everybody in my
audience knows who they are I don't see
it as even remotely likely that Joe
Biden picks Nina Turner or Stacey Abrams
so let me know your thoughts who do you
think Biden is most likely to select
versus who would you like Joe Biden to
select interested in hearing from you
you can let me know on Twitter at D
Pakman